là on va démarrer d'ici 5 minutes euh je
vais passer en tête sur la sur le convoi
tout ralentir pour se faire entendre des
pouvoirs publics desès 6h ce matin plus
d'une quinzaine de tracteurs ont conduit
une opération escargot sur la N12 et la
12 entre mé et le triangle de rquencour
après des actions menées hier dans le
secteur de Houdan la colère s'intensifie
à l'initiative de la Fédération
Départementale des syndicats
d'exploitants agricoles d'Île-de-France
les producteurs dénonce la hausse des
taxes et des normes environnementales
jugées trop contraignantes les
revendications bon se résume à TR sur
trois angles il y a la dignité du métier
qu' l'on a pu de la part de nos élus il
y a l'aspect revenu qui est très
important pour nous parce que
aujourd'hui c'est le ner de la guerre
c'est ce qui nous fait vivre et puis
après il y a tout tout le côté normatif
avec la surtransposition des des normes
franco-françaises avant on se metit du
cols avec un un un produit qui traitait
la semance qui protégeait la plante
contre les insectes pendant 3 semaines
après la levé donc maintenant il est
interdit ce produit là il y a une
semaine on a on a passé le traitement en
folière le pulvérisation en folière avec
un insecticide qui marche plus ou moins
bien TR fois dans la semaine pour
protéger la culture pour arriver à ce
qu'elle lève suffisamment pied lavant on
avait pas besoin de tout ça Stéphane et
céréali sur une propriété d'une
trentaine d'hectares dans les ivelines
et le valdoise PER de de enfants il ne
les encourage pas à reprendre ces TER à
vivre de son métier pour lui une vraie
passion on n pas rémunéré à à ce qu'on
devrait être on c'est un métier qui
crève la fin qu'on crève la fin quand
j'ai payé tous mes traitements mes
engrais sil me reste même pas allez 1000
€ pour faire l'année pour faire l'année
sur l'autoroute A12 TR voix sur 4 étai
neutralisé aux alentours de 8h le temps
de parcours entre bois d'Arc et
reconcours était d' 1h15 au lieu de 6
selon les données citadins le Premier
ministre Gabriel Atal fera des annonces
en faveur des agriculteurs ce vendredi
pour cette mobilisation à l'échelle
nationale